Buonasera Buonasera a tutti
Grazie per essere qui grazie a tutta
l'organizzazione per avermi invitato è
una grande emozione un grande piacere un
grande onore proprio essere qui a fare
due chiacchiere con voi Inizio subito
dicendo che quando mi hanno chiamato per
venire a parlare
davanti a tutti voi e mi hanno detto del
discorso da fare riguardo i limiti
sono stato colpito perché a novembre è
uscito il mio ultimo P che si chiama
Alchimia dove all'interno
questa parola
Nell'aria si sente spesso Cioè non c'è
proprio come parola nel Nei testi Ma
nell'area cioè questa parola perché ehm
i limiti sono stati quelli che mi hanno
fatto scrivere l'ultimo album o comunque
ho cercato di trarre il positivo e
negativo da questa parola per metterli
in musica
ed è per questo che tramite la mia
esperienza personale voglio raccontarvi
un po' quello che per me sono i limiti E
come li cerco di gestirli e di vederli
nella musica ma nella vita ed è per
questo che ho chiamato la mia il mio
speech i limiti il bene e il male quindi
quello che può far bene
e prendere da di buono da questa parola
e quello che può invece bloccarci
fermarci e Nella peggiore delle ipotesi
rovinare proprio ehm la vita al lavoro
eccetera iniziamo ehm con la parte del
di quello che io ho messo tra diciamo le
parti Buone le parti del bene Ehm avere
limiti a volte può essere una cosa
positiva Se tu sai comunque
gestirli e riesce a concentrarti in
quello che che vuoi fare per esempio
nella mia musica
sono stato
tantissime volte con questi pensieri di
non essere abbastanza o di non avere
limiti di voler sempre di più E questa
cosa mi portava non godermi momenti e
godermi quello che avevo e concentrarmi
sul mio talento e sul mio studio ognuno
quello che ha Insomma quindi averne in
questo caso per me può essere un bene
ovvero sapere dove io ehm posso arrivare
mi fa concentrare ehm su quella cosa su
quella determinata cosa mmm mi fa
insomma avere il Focus e L'obiettivo è
la mia lista scorsa settimana mi ha
parlato di questa di questa di queste
parole dal latino che sono Limes e limen
che un po' limiti e la differenza tra le
due è che una
è praticamente tu hai un confine e vai
avanti con con esso Quindi come se tu
avessi una armatura e va avanti e
l'altro invece è una prigione Quindi sei
comunque limitato ma rimani fermo e tra
le varie tra le varie cose della parte
appunto positiva di questa di questa
parola è che
conoscere i propri limiti
può far sì che
non ti deconcenti da da dal tuo
obiettivo cosa che invece appunto tante
volte molti di noi facciamo comunque
personalmente facciamo Questa invece è
la parte del di quello che può portare
la parte negativa ovvero avere limiti
mentali i social Per quanto possano
comunque darci una mano e quindi non
avere limiti ad arrivare a tantissime
persone possono comunque limitarci
perché siamo sempre continuamente a
vedere la vita degli altri a fare quello
che che fanno gli altri a voler essere
come quelli avere un proprio tipo di
limite fisico mentale eh di limita Mmm
ad essere chiuso comunque ehm
con gli altri
con le diversità che possono essere
sessuali etnie e quindi queste quando il
limite ti ti blocca e diventa una
prigione mentale è una cosa molto grave
e quindi bisogna sempre
trarre del bene ma conoscere anche
quando questa questa parola può
essere un problema per esempio anche le
paure sono un grande limite nel mio
lavoro per esempio conosco tantissimi
colleghi che hanno paura di viaggiare e
di prendere l'aereo e hanno paura di
uscire per attacchi di panico o comunque
si sentono
che non vogliono parlare con quella
persona cercano di non andare in
determinati posti quindi questo può
comunque limitare un network quindi
conoscere quella persona di trovarsi al
momento giusto penso che noi anche
giovani abbiamo bisogno di conoscere i
nostri limiti ma di
oltrepassarli anche quando ci bloccano
Io tra le varie cose
tra le varie cose tra il canto la musica
la produzione faccio i corsi ai ragazzi
e insegno musica ehm alza il Lewis a
Roma all'officina Pasolini e sono due
realtà molto importanti a Roma ed è una
cosa che ehm
dico spessissimo ragazzi
noto subito Chi ha l'intelligenza il
coraggio di capire che è un bene quando
tu sai di avere un limite per esempio
sul canto sullo strumento c'è anche io
vorrei suonare ehm la tromba come miles
Ma non so farlo quindi il limite di
capire e di avere la morbidità da
maturità di capire che non posso farlo
non riesco a farlo ma
qualcuno mi ha dato un talento nel canto
nella musica e quindi mi concentra al
100% nel canto e studio quello faccio
ognuno c'ha la propria strada ed è
secondo me è fondamentale capire che
tutti devi
concentrare e devi iniziare ad
apprezzare quello che hai e non quello
che non hai ehm per questo che già al
pianoforte perché come prima cosa
oltre al
al parlare la cosa che mi riesce meglio
appunto a cantare esprimermi in musica
dopo vi farò ascoltare un brano che si
chiama Affogo che è tratto da Alchimia
che LP che è uscito a novembre e dove
all'interno potrete cogliere queste
sensazioni e lì dove il limite mi ha
fermato e lì dove Appunto Invece sono
riuscito a oltrepassarlo Infatti il
brano si chiama Fogo Ma comunque non ha
foki ma trovo sempre la forza di
risalire e di andare avanti Quindi di
oltrepassare il confine ehm Ritornando
al discorso dei corsi ehm
a volte sono anche molto duro e diretto
coi ragazzi però eh capita molte volte
che i ragazzi vogliono fare tante cose e
non si concentrano su una fatta bene per
esempio nel nel mio caso musica in
tecnica o o nei brani quindi questa è
una parola limite che che ogni giorno mi
mi è dentro di me perché la riporto agli
altri e la riporto in me stesso Ehm
detto questo voglio appunto chiuderervi
chiudere questa questa chiacchiera con
ehm con con questo brano e si chiama
Affogo quindi Grazie a tutti per essere
venuti e chi chi vuole ci vediamo domani
che faremo un concerto con con la mia
band qui eh
Spero di vedervi Grazie
[Musica]
immagina di essere migliore di quello
che pensi
Immagina di dare un nome e quello che
senti
un insieme di vedere la luce nel buio
pesto
Insomma non aver paura del resto
Ma c'è tutto più alto sai per cadere giù
immaginavo labirinto non riesco a uscire
più
Immagina Il mare d'inverno che mi
ricordo
temi il corpo umano
tutti amanti prima sul mio collo i
giorni passano
e di che vado a fondo un tuffo nel mare
[Musica]
ci penso se fossi ancora se fossi ancora
lì
ancora in piedi senza cadere mai
[Musica]
Grazie
grazie Ci vediamo allora domani
[Musica]
Ribadisco nel ringraziare tutto il 3DS
tutta l'organizzazione ringrazio voi è
un grande onore ed è veramente
Un'emozione da essere qui però spero
Insomma che sia andato bene Grazie ciao
a tutti
[Applauso]